Now I'm going to introduce you to a
lazy version of the RC memory model. And it's
called LRC, stands for lazy RC. Now this is
the structure of your pilot program so a thread
acquires a lot, does the data accessing, releases the
lock. Another thread may acquire the same lock. And
if the critical section for P1 Precedes the critical
section for P2, then the RC memory model requires
that, at the point of release, you
ensure that all the modifications that have been
made on processor P1, that is, the
coherence actions. That are commensurate with those data
acceses, are all communicated to all the
peer processes including P2. Then you release the
lock. That's the semantic. And this is
what is called eager release consistency, meaning that
at the point of release you're insuring that the
whole system is cache coherent The whole system is
cache coherent at the point of release, then you
release from the lock. And the cache coherence is
with respect to the set of data accesses that
have gone on on this process up to this
point, that's what we are ensuring has been communicated
and made consistent on all the processes. Now let's
say that the timeline looks like this and P1's
release happened at this point. And P2's acquire of
the same lock happened at a much later point
in time. That's the luck of the draw in
terms of how the computation went, and so there
is this time window between P1's release of the
lock and P2's acquisition of the same lock. Now
if you think about it there's an opportunity for procrastination.
Now we saw that procrastination often helps in
system design. We've seen this in mutual exclusion locks.
If you insert delay between successive trials of
trying to get the lock, that actually results in
better performance. We saw that in processes scheduling
too. Instead of eagerly scheduling the next available task
Maybe you want to wait for a task
that has more affinity to your processor. That results
in performance advantage. So procrastination often is
a good friend of system design. So
here again there is an opportunity for
procrastination. So Lazy RC is another instance
where procrastination may actually help in optimizing
the system performance. The idea is that,
rather than performing all the coherence actions
at the point of release. Don't do it,
procrastinate. Wait till the acquire actually happens.
At the point of acquire, take all the
coherence actions before allowing this acquire to succeed.
So the key point is that you're deafening
the point at which you ensure that all
the coherence actions are complete to the point
of acquisition as opposed to the point of
release. Even if all the coherence actions commensurate
with the data accesses that have gone on
up until this release point, are not yet
complete when we hit the release, go ahead.
Release the lock, but if the next lock acquisition
happens, at that point, make sure that all
the coherence actions are complete. So in other words,
you get an opportunity to overlap computation with
communication once again in this window of time between
release of a lock, and the acquisition of the same lock.